this area surrounding allegion stadium
is home to dozens of industrial and
manufacturing businesses
now the county hopes to transform it
into a thriving center of entertainment
i've been driving up and down these
streets for a long time and you see the
same businesses they don't really tend
to
come and go very often they're very well
established everybody has their own
networks you know
the dumbbell man which supplies fitness
centers on the strip and in residential
areas
has been at reno and valley view for 15
years they're now within the boundaries
of the recently approved 1.25
square mile stadium district anything
that brings more entertainment value
makes brings the property value up makes
the area a little bit nicer we love that
a key focus of the district is to draw
people in year round these renderings
show more walkable and bikeable areas
taking inspiration from cities such as
portland and san francisco
the district will also house new
restaurants retail
and entertainment we really do want to
make the most out of the investment that
the raiders have made
the investment that the public's made
and this will really help do that
over the past few years surrounding
businesses have provided input on the
plan
mickey zimmerman says many are not
retailers and don't directly deal with
the public
so the possibility of changes or even
moving doesn't have a drastic
impact business changes you have to be
flexible you have to
be able to respond to changes so i think
it's just part of business it's fine
with us
kate houston 8 news now